you want a a comeback yeah all right
we'll give you another one what about
this name lindsay lohan she's coming
back too
well i love lindsay and deadline reports
that she just signed a multi-film deal
with netflix uh yeah and she's already
doing a holiday movie for them called
falling for christmas and here is the
plotline she plays a spoiled hotel
heiress gone skiing who falls hits her
head gets amnesia and falls in love with
the rugged ski lodge owner played by
court overstreet okay i'm watching that
um it comes out in december but here's
the thing lilo went away for a minute
right she you know she was always
everyone always said she was so talented
she had her struggles that were very
public she went away and now she's
coming back with a gusto i am here for
it lindsay i cannot wait you guys too
i love her
i i'm excited about this i think lindsay
lohan is so talented beyond hello do you
know many times i've seen herbie the
love bug do you know how many times i
have seen freaky friday with jamie lee
curtis uh apparently trap mean girls
come on
no i love her and i loved her music and
yeah she's a good person she's a good
person she's like nice and cool and fun
but you know but it says something
because for she was so talented and then
there was a moment in pop culture where
she was almost like a punch line you
know and that's so sad to say but we all
saw it happen and then i love that she
just sort of on her own terms push pause
and then now it's like hey remember me
i'm this talented and i'm a superstar
and now i'm going to rule the world
again i love it
i was the punchline too
i was and i get it and you just have to
keep the most open minds and opens open
hearts so i'm here for this i'm here
we're both in
all right switching gears uh question
for everybody what is the hottest
hangout in america right now think about
it huh huh i don't know
where is it well think about in the 50s
we had drive-in theaters remember you go
i wasn't there but you know and then
in the 60s they went to the bowling
alley apparently
okay i feel like i've been to drive-ins
and bowling alleys but go on well here's
what they say is the the new hottest
hangout refinery29 says it's going back
to the mall
the mall
yeah people are mauling it up again uh
malls are ready too 50 of retailers have
renovated over the last two years and
new stores are coming in amazon has a
new high-tech style shop okay and
rihanna's savage uh ex fenty store oh
yeah oh yeah well that just went into a
mall in vegas oh i love vegas and so i
uh i'm going i know you're going to vape
i'm planning a girls trip to vegas
will you go to the mall
um
there yeah there's like a big mall there
is it like caesar's mall or something
and it's huge
all the stores are like so expensive i
can't i'm not one of those like i that's
not my style my clothes are free city
sweatpants and vintage t-shirts that's
true whatever mall has that yeah
that's my mall
do you
do you love them all like i love them
all i mean a place where you can get
like you know a half price pashmina and
an orange julius is like that's where i
want to live my life if there's not a
sparrow in your mall i'm not going or
like a la sports sack
a lady foot locker i want a little
quartz sack and a hot dog on a stick yes
please
[Music]